if you're a fan of EXO Kitty and you're
literally thirsting for more check out
these three Soju cocktails inspired by
the characters from the show for Yuri we
decided to go with mango cow Pico as the
mixer it's both sweet tart much like the
character herself
for a day we decided to go with milkus I
love milkus the yogurt flavored drink
goes down soft with a hint of Fizz
reminds us of our favorite timid harp
who's also not afraid to back up his
friends for Kitty we decided to go with
the yogurt drink because we know it's a
classic drink that she likes also it's a
popular Soju cocktail that many Koreans
enjoy and amongst the soldier cocktails
this one's my favorite drink responsibly